for liam and nolan avid england fans
it has been an emotional journey dad
liam
was just eight when england crashed out
of the euros in the semi-finals
in 96. he's hoping his son
who's the same age as he was then will
be spared the pain
and the heartache this time around we've
planning a new style we've got strength
in depth
players to come off the bench and gareth
seems to be getting the tactics right
each time so
so far so good it's good to see
england playing well and the more
trying the hardest for the country being
an england fan
has never been easy but as this
generation's heroes
are stamped on the back of shirts for
many it feels as though times
are changing gareth southgate's team
are no doubt stronger on paper than
denmark
but as the team finalized their tactics
they know it will be
a difficult game we're very excited
about the game
that's for sure and
we know that we're going to have
tremendous support throughout the
country so it's a that's a great feeling
for us
if england win they'll face either italy
or spain
played in the shadow of a pandemic these
euros have offered a glimpse of
normality
and some relief in what has been a tough
time
the sense of expectation around this
england team is growing
all the time as the clock ticks down to
their clash with destiny
at the home of english football and they
are the bookies favorite
but we should remember that denmark has
not only been at this point before
they went on to be european champions in
1992.
at this danish restaurant in central
london they are gearing up for the big
match
owner soren jessen says england would be
foolish
to take victory for granted this team is
the best we've had in a very long time
and they're going from strength to
strength and they've
had a terrible the awful start to the
tournament that turned around and became
a wonderful recovery story and the same
thing
um seems to follow the team right now so
i think they could go
all the way this will in many ways be
england's biggest test in this
tournament
but there is an energy about this team
and a belief
that this is their moment alex rossi
sky news wembley the